- Hey, good afternoon everyone
and welcome to the session.
My name is Sachneet
and I lead the Solutions
Architecture team at Impetus.
Today I'll be talking about
how we are helping enterprises
unlock the GenAI potential
with automated modernization
of their legacies,
the data that they have
accumulated over decades
to the AWS platform.
First, about Impetus Technologies,
we are empowering the
intelligent enterprise.
We are into data, cloud and
GenAI thought-leadership.
Globally 3,600 plus.
We are serving more than 30
plus fortune hundred customers.
We are among the top AWS
services and solution partners
and we have been delivering
to 30 plus fortune hundred customers
with a commitment to success.
We have established a
center of excellence,
AWS Center of Excellence at Impetus,
and that's where we are also the top
service partner as well.
We are premier tier services partner.
We are number one in
the ETL migration space.
We have migrated a number of customers
from their legacies to AWS Glue.
We have more than 10 plus
services and solutions
listed on AWS marketplace
and we are D2E certified as well.
Now talking about the
intelligent enterprise.
This is a portfolio of Impetus solutions
and the services portfolio.
Now starting with the data
and cloud engineering.
We start with
defining and designing
the data strategies,
cloud strategies, GenAI
strategies for our customers.
And for that we've also built some
solutions and accelerators.
A data platform accelerator
that really helps jumpstart,
create data platforms.
A solution accelerator called Prism
which brings unified observability.
And then we have solutions around
data workloads and app modernization.
I'll be speaking about that,
but starting from, you know,
creating those strategies,
whether that's cloud
data or GenAI strategy
and then putting that to implementation
and successfully productionizing is what
we really have expertise around.
We have a dedicated DevOps practice,
everything from CI/CD, AI and ML ops.
We've been delivering
that to our customers.
Things around GenAI services.
We also have something called GenAI Labs
where we really help
accelerate the design of
ideas and solutions for our customers.
And also helping them develop
any rack based frameworks
that they want to create
or anything that they want
to build around Agentic AI,
as well as taking care of
any AI based governance
that needs to be in place.
Now talking about GenBI services,
we've been helping our customer
in the modernization space
and otherwise to help, you know,
import their legacy BI's
to these modern platforms
leveraging GenBI,
wherein for example, if you
have thousands of reports,
you don't really have to
report or redesign all of them.
GenBI can take care of most
of those reports for them,
for you, especially the ad hoc reports.
And then
summarizing all this,
this is how we've been helping
deliver an intelligent enterprise
and enterprise that can
make very informed decisions
using the insights from the data
that they have accumulated
over all these decades.
And now let's talk about
how are we helping
transforming the data ecosystem
for it to be ready for the GenAI era.
Now, first start with
a survey that says that
90% of the leaders who are looking at,
you know, the GenAI space and the AI space
first want to prioritize the modernization
of the legacies that they have.
Because they may be running
an EDW/ETL for decades.
There's a lot of business
logic accumulated there,
so they want to prioritize.
And similar number of leaders
feel that modernizing all these data
and using it in the GenAI
era is the key to success.
And at the same time, there
is a certain percentage
that feels that there
are certain impediments,
certain challenges to modernization.
Now we are all aligned
to all these servers
that are out there and then
we have solved this problem
with our tool solution
accelerator called LeapLogic
that really helps accelerate
such modernizations.
Now before we talk about modernization,
the first question is,
how should we strategize, right?
What should be our
approach for modernization?
Should we take everything as is,
the decades of investments
that you have on your warehouse,
on your ETL, on your BA side,
but that was architected for
those legacy frameworks, right?
You cannot retrofit that
to a modern platform,
but then you, do you throw that away
or is there a way to
reuse that business logic?
And once you have made that decision,
there's another very important question.
How big is this effort?
Are you looking at six months on effort,
a one year or a two years of effort?
Now given let's say it's six
months on an eight months.
What happens to the
business as usual, right?
So these are some of
the important questions
we help answer our customers
as part of our strategy,
strategizing a modernization for them
as part of our modernization
methodology and approach.
So the first thing that we start with is
creating and using a balanced approach,
proposing a balanced approach,
which means that
if you have a lot of legacy
around EDW/ETL, BI analytics,
we feel that a balance approach around,
you know, taking 80% of that
as is, but modernizing it
to the target platform,
which is pattern based transformation.
Now there could be 20% of it,
which could be the technical debt
that may need let's say
rewrite or engineer,
but we have seen this 80-20 rule
works very well for most
of the legacies out there.
And then comes the methodology part.
So what you see on the screen is
the methodology we use.
On the left hand side are
some of the popular legacies
we support today.
So you'll see EDWs, ETLs,
analytics, Hadoop, all that.
On the right hand side you'll see
some of the services on AWS side
where we are able to migrate
all these legacies to
and that to in an automated fashion.
In the center you'll see
the four step methodology.
The first one is assess.
So this is the most critical part
because this is where we
strategize the modernization.
So what we do is, we
look at your legacies,
we assess them
and there are some key
insights we extract out.
First.
What is the overall score?
What are the volume metrics?
Second.
Well, how complex is the business logic
that's contained out there?
Third.
What is the technical debt?
If an EDW has been running
there for 20 years,
there must be a lot of
technical data out there.
The technical, that could
be the business logic,
the technical that
could be the data around
or the technical that
could be the complexity
of the business logic itself.
We are able to extract that out.
Fourth.
We are able to do a lineage
and dependency analysis of everything
you are running on your
legacy ecosystem today,
which essentially means is,
we are able to create a mapping
from your orchestration to ETL,
to your EDW and then to the BI
and end-to-end lineage
and dependency analysis.
And using all this information,
we are able to come up with
the right strategy for you,
right timelines for you,
right target architecture for you,
and also the right recommendations for you
as part of the modernization.
So once we have defined the
right strategy and approach,
the second step is the
transformation itself.
Now this is where the magic happens
because the tool is able to auto transform
90 to 95% of your legacy code
into the modern AWS platform,
which essentially means is if
you're running an Informatica
or a data stage or a Teradata or an Oracle
and you wanna move that to
Glue and Redshift combination,
the tool will do that 90 to 95%
in an automated fashion for you.
Now there's minimal manual efforts,
five to 10 person
that's taken care by the Impetus SME.
So what we deliver to you is
a successful modernization
within fixed timelines.
So the transformation step is where
the most of the acceleration happens,
and at the same time
we take care of
standardization, optimizations
that have to be implicit.
The third step is the validation
part where we take care of
everything from cell to cell
based data validation,
as well as validating each and
every piece of business logic
that has been transformed.
And the last part is
the operationalization.
So when I say we deliver
your successful migration,
what I meant was that we
don't just transform the code
and dump the code and say a goodbye.
We make sure that we are
productionizing it for you.
And this is where the operationalization
comes into the picture,
where we make sure we are building
the right CI/CD processes for you,
any security governance processes for you
and you're able to productionize
your legacy code transform to the
AWS target platform.
Now this slide talks about
some of the automation levels we have.
You'll see that for most
of the EDW and ETLs,
we have very good up
to 90-95% of automation
already available.
This is the four step
methodology in more detail.
I've already spoken about it.
Now let's compare LeapLogic
to some of the tools out there.
So if you're thinking of modernization,
you're already into modernization phase,
you may have seen a
plethora of tools out there.
Now this is a comparison of
how LeapLogic is way ahead of those tools.
Let's talk about some of those parameters.
The first one is the
end-to-end automation.
You'll find the tools in the
industry that may do ETL or EDW
or Hadoop or BI,
but in your ecosystem you
have all of those four.
Now do you choose one tool for each
or do you do use a tool that
does everything for you?
This is the first.
So, LeapLogic does everything end to end.
The second one is
how does the transformation
actually happen, right?
Are these the tool just doing
a line by line conversion
or is it really understanding
the business logic behind it
and then transforming it
based on a pattern based transformation?
Again, LeapLogic really
differentiates itself
because it does a pattern
based modernization
and covers all the workload types.
The third one.
How do you do interdependency and lineage?
If you have a EDW that's
running for two decades,
you cannot really transform that in once.
You cannot boil the ocean altogether,
you'll have to break it down.
But how do you break it down, right?
You cannot break it down
without any intelligence.
You need to figure out how
is the dependency mapped.
This is where again LeapLogic
differentiates because it has
all that end-to-end mapping
to plan a phase wise migration plan
versus a very dumb
chunking of your scope of
work for modernization.
Then the fourth one is the
kind of automation it brings.
With 90 to 95% of automation,
it really, really accelerates
the modernization.
Then what kind of
validation do we support?
A cell by cell validation ensures that
we are doing a validation
to the most granular level.
The tools out there do not
go to that granularity.
Then is it customizable
for the enterprise level?
Let's say you are using
some custom frameworks.
Can we output?
Can we generate the code
according to those frameworks or not?
Yes, LeapLogic can.
But do all the tools out there do that?
No.
Then how do we make sure that
we are adhering to all the SLAs
and delivering the performance
to you on the target platform?
LeapLogic ensures that because
while it does the transformation,
it ensures that all the
optimizations are implicit
and finally
ensuring a risk-free migration with
zero disruption to your
business as usual because
it has all that linears dependency mapping
and it is very well planned.
So this is what differentiate LeapLogic
from all the tools out there
ensuring that you have
a successful migration.
Now how does that really help
in the GenBI space as well, right?
I spoke about that.
Other than the EDW/ETL you are running,
we also support BI tools.
You may be running, let's say Tableau,
you may be running some other BI tools
and you wanna modernize that,
but you want to leverage GenBI.
The tool will really assess and tell you
what kind of patterns you run today
or what kind of reports you
run today on your legacy
and how that can be transformed
to the modern platform
and what GenBI can do for you.
For example,
a lot of self-serve reports
do not really need
the reports to be
converted from Tableau to,
let's say the AWS platform.
QuickSight, along with Amazon Queue,
could really build those
self-serve dashboards
for you, right?
Which means if you have let's say
5,000 self-serve reports,
you don't really have to
rebuild all of them, right?
So that's the kind of GenBI readiness,
the LeapLogic tool is able to bring
because it is able to assess and tell you
how GenBI can really help
in your reporting landscape.
Now finally, what's the
advantage of using LeapLogic
for any of those modernizations?
4x faster transformations.
2x lower cost.
1.5x faster validation
and overall compared to
any manual migration,
2x less effort.
And we have done this time and again.
We have done more than
200 plus migrations.
All successfully delivered.
We have transformed over a
hundred million lines of code
and the grammar engine today that
back sleep logic is so
robust that it has seen
most of the patterns out there in EDW,
EDW analytics and big data space.
And with up to 95% of automation,
it ensures that you have
at least 50 to 75% of
reduction in your migration
and modernization cycle.
Some of the case studies talking about
United Airlines, right?
They had an application
running on legacy today,
which really helped, you know,
provide customers with
realtime information.
But since it was running on legacy,
it was really slow.
We modernized that using
LeapLogic to the AWS platform
and ultimately delivered 70% effort
and 22% time savings for them.
It was a Teradata migration to Redshift
that we really accelerated
through LeapLogic
and ultimately for that
application itself,
United Airlines was actively
able to reduce 50% wait time
for their passengers
and 50% increase in the bookings as well.
So we did not really just
deliver an accelerated migration,
but also brought a a lot of business value
for United Airlines.
Similarly for American Express
Teradata, Ab Initio migration,
the application that they were running,
we transformed that with
over 70% automation.
I like to also talk about
how we helped Bank United
with their reporting challenges.
So the challenge was that the data
that they were bringing was
taking more than 12 hours
to be ready for reporting,
which was defeating the purpose
of making informed and timely decisions.
With LeapLogic, we did the assessment,
we came up the modernization approach
and we not only delivered
the transformation and the modernization
with 85% automation and acceleration,
but we delivered efficiencies
that the time that it
was taking on legacy,
more than 12 hours,
we were able to reduce that
by almost more than 50%
and they were able to make
informed decisions in a timely fashion.
So this is the kind of
transformational impact
we have been able to
bring to our customers.
Now,
we've also come up with a new accelerator,
a new product.
So LeapLogic does the
transformation modernization,
it really accelerates that.
But once you have moved to the cloud,
how do you make sure that
you are continuously optimizing your cost,
at the same time you are
getting a unified view of
your cloud spend as well
as our observability,
a unified observability.
This is where we have
come up with with Prism,
which is industry's
first AI enabled solution
for unified observability.
So it does a number of things.
First one, it'll give
you a unified view of
multi-cloud and data platforms.
So if you're using let's say AWS
and you're also using
some data platforms like
Databricks or Snowflake or
maybe also using multi-cloud,
you don't have to go
to different dashboards
to see what you are running and
what costs you are incurring.
You will get one unified
view for it through Prism.
That's one.
Second.
It is AI powered
and it has predictive analytic insights,
which means is which,
what it means is that
the observability insights
that it will bring to you,
it'll also make some
predictive recommendations.
It'll tell you that there
are certain anomalies
that should be sorted out and
how they should be sorted.
It'll also come up with
recommendation around the spend.
It'll tell you where you are spending
and why you are spending that
and what is the approach to optimize that.
So, and it is all AI based.
And the last one is the
intelligence automation
and the governance that it brings.
What that means is
that it has an ML driven
forecasting for you.
You are anticipating some good growth
on your cloud data platforms,
but how do you really quantify that
based on historical data
or what you're doing today?
So Prism can really come
up with that AI based,
very informed forecasting for you.
It also has the ability of smart tagging,
which means you may be running
hundred of applications on a cloud.
How do you know which
application is consuming
what kind of resources?
So you can do smart tagging through Prism
and the dashboard, the single dashboard
that you will have
will tell you that this
particular business group
or this application is
actually running these services
and this is the kind of
cost that you're incurring.
And finally,
it also has the ability of,
you know, making the
recommendations for you
across applications but with intelligence,
which means is, you may
be running an EC2 instance
that is costing you too much,
but rather than, you
know, in a dumb way coming
and saying, "Hey, reduce
the size of this EC2",
the tool is aware that you are running
a very mission critical
application on this EC2.
You cannot just bring it down
or you cannot just
bring the down the size.
So the recommendations that you get
are very application
aware and intelligent.
So this is the kind of
value at Prism also brings.
So if you've already modernized
or you're modernizing to cloud,
Prism is a tool that
you really need because
this is what will ensure
a unified observability
and dashboarding for you.
With that, I'd like you to invite,
like you to visit our booth 1553.
We'll happy to speak about Prism in detail
or LeapLogic in detail or GenAI and BI.
We'll love to discuss
where you are on your modernization space
or what you are doing on
the GenAI or GenBI space.
At the same time, we'll love
you to we,
we're hosting our event today
and we'll like to invite you.
Please do visit our booth.
We'll love to have a chit
chat over some drinks with you
and speak about the
modernization and others.
We also have this here,
so we'll love to distribute and have you
come along to the party
and have some chitchat
and some conversations
around modernization
and GenAI with you all.
With that, thank you for time. Thank you.